la réalisatrice et productrice angelina jolie et
son mari brad pitt viennent d'émerger
sur le tapis rouge l'air absolument
magnifique l'
air ravi d'être ici à sydney l'
air ravi
de présenter ce film sur lequel elle a
travaillé si inlassablement au cours
des deux dernières années quel moment pour  sydney
la scène du divertissement
l'industrie du cinéma tous les amis et la
famille de ces deux et aussi les fans
vous êtes tous venus en force
ce soir pour célébrer cette histoire ce
film et aussi tout leur travail acharné nous
aurons une conversation avec angelina  un
peu plus tard dans la soirée avec le
producteur matt bear miyavi qui joue l'
oiseau dans le film et aussi jack
o'connell qui joue la star louis
zamparini
au vietnam ce jeune garçon est maintenant
enseignant et
a été opéré et a fait restaurer son site
mais le  la fondation est vraiment vous savez
été si incroyablement soutenue par la
communauté australienne et je veux juste
remercier tout le monde de nous aider et euh vous
savez que nous sortons vraiment  il
fait de son mieux pour garder les rêves de fred
vivants et tu sais que ruth n'était
qu'un petit 1987 il était ici donc ma fille
anna louise est sa filleule et euh pour
que toute sa vie ce mec
vient d'être là-bas en train
de faire beaucoup beaucoup  beaucoup de chirurgies sont
beaucoup de gens et nous avons l'
institut d'ophtalmologie le plus étonnant
c'est un centre d'excellence dans l'
écriture de la survivante de Katmandou, tout comme
louis zamparini alors
que la réalisatrice descend cette
rangée de personnes, elle est si merveilleuse
et généreuse avec elle  le temps euh tous ces
merveilleux fans qui prennent des photos
avec angelina jolie
comme je l'ai mentionné, ce seront des moments
que je suis sûr que vous chérirez tous pour les
années à venir parce que
ça se passe autour c'est un vrai boom et
pas seulement en termes d'emploi  comme
vous l'avez mentionné et impliquant tant de
personnes différentes, mais je pense que
l'esprit des australiens aussi,
ils sont tellement passionnés par le cinéma et
c'est génial de voir certains de ces gros
ho  llywood comme nous les appelons des
blockbusters tournés ici absolument je veux dire
comme nous savons tous que l'australie frappe au-dessus de
son poids nous avons une fabuleuse télévision australienne
nous avons perdu son fils qui a été l'un des premiers
sur la scène à me sauver
et ouais c'est vraiment bon  expérience
à faire je passe un bon moment j'adore le
chemin de fer en
train de profiter de la procédure au moment où nous parlons nous
avons tellement d'invités qui montent le
tapis rouge le film commencera vers 7 h
30 ce soir aussi mon collègue
richard wilkins est au bout du
tapis comme  eh bien, qui était-il avec moi un
peu plus tôt, il discutait avec certaines
des stars de la réservation, mais à quel point
la foule sort-elle bien eh oh la foule a
été sensationnelle certains de ces signes euh
que nous avons déjà vus c'est la
saison pour  être julie
que j'aime vraiment beaucoup entrer dans la
période de noël
et quelques-unes des dames sont assez heureuses de
voir euh
voir brad ici aussi c'était une belle
surprise n'est-ce pas c'est juste une
chose énorme à subir en particulier  y
quand c'était votre choix mais je suppose un deux à
quel point la première mondiale est excitante je n'arrête pas d'
oublier que ce n'est pas seulement une première
c'est la première fois que le monde
va réellement voir ce film magnifique d'
où le titre première mondiale ouais
première
avec poitrine et  cancer de l'ovaire mon arrière-grand-
mère avait 68 ans ma grand-mère avait 44 ans à nouveau
diagnostiquée à 53 ans.